KATHERINE MILLER:
Hi, everyone.
And welcome to today's Google
Developers Live session on the
Udacity HTML5 Game Development
Course.
My name is Katherine Miller.
I'm a member of the Developer
Marketing Team here at Google.
And I'll be your moderator
today.
And I'm very excited to be
joined by four incredible
guests who are going to be
talking about this program.
We have Sean Bennett, Course
Architect from Udacity.
Sebastian Thrun, who is the CEO
of Udacity, as well as a
Google Fellow.
We have Peter Lubbers, who is
a program manager for Chrome
Developer Relations.
And Colt McAnlis, who is a
developer advocate for Chrome.
Little bit of background
on this course.
It launched about nine days
ago and already has over
46,000 people enrolled.
And to give you a little bit of
context, that's about three
times the size of the current
Stanford student body.
So over the course of nine days,
three times the size of
Stanford has enrolled and
started taking a course which
is pretty incredible.
So I'm really excited to be here
today to share with you
and have them share with you
a little bit about how this
course came to be, as well as
the power of massively open
online courses.
And so to get started, I'm going
to turn to my left and
have Sean and Sebastian
introduce themselves.
And then we'll move
over to the right.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Sean,
you start.
SEAN BENNETT: I'm
Sean Bennett.
I started at Udacity almost
a year ago now, I think.
I've been working on this course
with Colt and Peter and
Calvin Hu, who isn't here today
but is probably the
single person most responsible
for getting it out.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: Go ahead.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
And I'm Sebastian.
At Google I do work like Google
self-driving cars and
involved in Google Glass.
Little small projects.
But I really care about
changing education and
bringing high quality
education to
everybody in the world.
And I think no better place
to start than Google.
KATHERINE MILLER: Wonderful.
Thank you.
PETER LUBBERS: I'm
Peter Lubbers.
I'm Program Manager at Google
in the Chrome Developer
Relations Team.
Been with Google for
about a year.
And prior to that, I did a
lot of HTML5 training.
And been really excited just
working with this team and
taking the HTML5 training to
a huge scale that we're
seeing right now.
KATHERINE MILLER: And you really
live and breathe and
drive HTML5, don't you?
PETER LUBBERS: And drive, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: We have the
HTML5 license plate.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: And Sebastian
here has the
Udacity license plate.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: So we
came together.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Excellent.
COLT MCANLIS: And I'm
Colt McAnlis.
I've been with Google almost
two years now.
Wow.
Time flies.
In my previous life, I was
actually a game developer for
about 10 years, making tons of
fun stuff, as well as an
adjunct professor at Southern
Methodist University Guildhall
School of Video Game
Development.
So it's really kind of nice to
be able to take all of that
expertise and find a
new place for it.
KATHERINE MILLER: Mmhmm.
Excellent.
It was the--
I don't know what the word is.
It's not a trifecta--
quadfecta?
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: Has come
together to make this
incredible thing happen.
So Sean, I'm actually going to
start and turn it over to you.
So what is this?
What has just launched?
SEAN BENNETT: So this is our
course on HTML5 game
development.
And really what it's about
is how do you take game
development principles that
we've learned over the past 20
or 30 years and port that to
building an amazing experience
on the web?
And we started this--
six, nine?
PETER LUBBERS: About
six months ago.
SEAN BENNETT: Six months ago?
PETER LUBBERS: Somewhere
around there.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Wow.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: And I met
Colt in a cafeteria here.
And he started spewing game
development stuff at me.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: And
he still is.
SEAN BENNETT: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: It was funny too,
because Sean's eyes just
went blank.
Just like, hey, we we're
thinking about a course.
And they're like cool--
blah, blah, blah.
And he just blanks.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: Yep.
KATHERINE MILLER: And it really
goes to show you the
power of connectivity at
Google cafes as well.
SEAN BENNETT: It does.
PETER LUBBERS: Absolutely.
COLT MCANLIS: Good food
brings good times.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Excellent.
Well, that's really exciting.
And this course has come
together on Udacity.
And it really has, in many
ways, a folkloric story.
When Peter came to
me and said--
I'm like, oh, I've
heard that story.
So I think we'd really to hear
from the horse's mouth.
So can you tell us a little bit
about how Udacity came to
be and what it really is?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I give
you the Cliff Notes.
About two years ago, Peter
Norvig-- who's a director here
at Google-- and I tend to teach
this class, Artificial
Intelligence, at Stanford.
And we listened to Sal Khan
talk about how his Khan
Academy reached tens of
millions of kids.
And honestly, we got jealous
and inspired.
So we took our class online.
We sent out one email.
And we got 160,000 students.
And we were blown away.
But more so we were blown away
by the type of students.
These are people from
all trades of life.
Kids as young as 11 years old.
People really old.
Soldiers in Afghanistan.
Mothers raising kids alone.
So we felt we could reach
a huge number of people.
And we've taken this to a great
new level at Udacity.
We've been working with a number
of companies, Google
being one of them, to really
bring to people the type of
skills that they need in the
work force to really get ready
for jobs in this space.
If you look at HTML5, it's
singly the most exciting thing
happening in computer
science today.
And no college teaches it.
So you can't get that skill
in a university.
And why don't colleges
teach it?
Well, it's so new that Google
cares about it.
And many other companies do.
But college professors haven't
quite caught up.
So we try to fill that gap.
KATHERINE MILLER: That's
really incredible.
And as I was chatting with
Peter yesterday, he said
there's actually a technology
tie in to how Udacity was
built, a connection
with Google.
So with our audience where we're
trying to inspire them
to be using Google technology,
we'd love to hear a little bit
about the underbelly
of Udacity if
you'd like to share.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We would not be
alive without Google's App
Engine, without Google's
amazing expertise.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Starting a
company that basically spans
all the way from instructional
design videos, quizzing, to
learning management, which is
the kind of [? source ?] that
keeps track of your progress.
To teach our portals and
[INAUDIBLE] teach us to
understand what's going on.
All within a year?
It would have been completely
impossible.
So now it's possible because
Google is just such an amazing
company with so many
amazing services.
But specifically excited that
we're also working with Google
in my home country on educating
the world and
bringing that content.
KATHERINE MILLER:
That's amazing.
And Peter, now, the other
side of that.
You had this amazing idea for
a course and needed to bring
that to life.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
When I joined Google,
I'd come from a
background of HTML5 training.
But this was instructor-led,
fly to some other country,
teach 10 people for two days.
And when I joined Google, one
of, of course, the main things
is we do things at
a large scale.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: So it was like,
how do you scale that up to--
SEBASTIAN THRUN: 40 people.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: How do
you double that?
And so the other thing at
Google, we're very interested
always in metrics.
And so one of the things about
a lot of the typical classic
online learning is you don't--
people go to a page.
They maybe look at a tutorial.
But we can't really tell whether
they've tried it.
A page view, ultimately,
is a vanity metric.
You can have 100,000
page views.
And nobody's learned anything.
So really it was kind of great
luck to kind of run into each
other in that space.
But we were really looking
at, how can we scale?
And how can we get
deeper metrics?
And now we can see who's
done a certain video.
But right after the videos--
and we'll talk a little bit
more about it later--
you get a challenge.
And you actually have
to do some coding.
And so with that in mind,
you really have--
we can see, hey, everyone was
able to pass this challenge.
But this one is really bad.
Probably reflects bad
on us as teachers.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: But the deeper
metrics, the scale, it's a
match made in heaven.
KATHERINE MILLER: Mmhmm.
That's really incredible.
And it's, in many ways, kind of
the philosophy of Google in
terms of trying new things,
building new things, getting
it out there.
Maybe having an amazing
moment.
Maybe having an oops moment.
And just kind of, what can
we learn from this?
PETER LUBBERS: Exactly.
KATHERINE MILLER: From a
pedagogical perspective for
teachers to have that instant
feedback is really powerful.
Is really powerful.
So Sean, a question for you.
And maybe for Colt as well.
You talked a little bit about
the importance of it being an
HTML5 course.
And really that this is
something that's so new and
innovative that it just
hasn't seeped into
standard curricula yet.
But why games?
SEAN BENNETT: I just wanted to
teach a game development
course, honestly.
KATHERINE MILLER: Fair enough.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: It's actually--
I think I proposed this
to you about seven or
eight months ago.
And I was just talking about,
you know, it'd be really cool
to teach an HTML5 course.
And so we were trying to think
of motivating examples.
And we're like, well, let's
build some games.
And then we got in contact
with Peter and Colt.
And it's like, well, how do we
go about building games?
I mean, we're not
game developers.
We don't know how this works.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: You've got one.
SEAN BENNETT: And more
importantly, how
do you teach it?
And I think one of the big
things here that we've learned
is that it's really important
to have code that you're
teaching around a project
that you're building.
A lot of our teaching is built
around, OK, they're going to
build this entire section
of the code base.
And they're going to understand
how it works at a
deep level.
KATHERINE MILLER: Mmhmm.
COLT MCANLIS: Growing up, I
had to teach myself how to
write video games.
This has been a passion of mine
since I was 12 years old.
I'm not gonna say how
old I am now.
But anyhow.
And early on--
imagine how much curriculum
you find now for
making video games.
It's in a lot of places.
Back then it was not.
And all through that sort of
toil coming up to becoming a
professional in the industry,
I always remembered, man, I
wish I could give something
back, which is why I got
involved with education
at SMU.
And one of the things that
always bothered me about
having something more standard
like that is that it's so slow
to turn around.
And that's why I love
getting involved
with the Udacity stuff.
We were able to take from
concept to first bits on the
screen in six months a full
course that's touching almost
50,000 users across the world
with a brand new technology
that everyone wants to know
and everyone wants to be a
part of that's literally on
the cutting edge of game
development.
Day-to-day, we get emails and
comments and people coming to
us asking about, how do we
make great HTML5 games?
And the fact that we have
a solution for that and
education for these people,
it's really--
it's mind blowing.
KATHERINE MILLER: And it really
seems, as well, that
the games is many ways the
mechanism that they're using
to learn the HTML5.
So it can in many ways serve
both of those purposes, both
creating something cutting edge
but actually creating
cutting edge games.
So it has kind of those
dual purposes.
PETER LUBBERS: I think one
additional thing to add to
that is the games tend to push
the boundaries of what's
possible on any platform.
That's true for desktop
applications or anything.
They demand so much
from the platform.
And it's a great way-- if it
works for games, then it will
probably work for--
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: Less
intense sites.
And just to add to that as well,
this course is built
around an actual
existing game.
And so it's a full-blown game
that Colt actually worked on
for months with a small team.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
That's actually worth
pointing out.
So having almost 10 years in
game development background,
the first thing what I did
when I came to Google was
said, hey, HTML5
is a big thing.
Let's actually take game
developers' view and apply it
to the technology.
Until that time, we'd heard a
lot of web developers trying
to make games.
And of course, they're coming
to that skill set from a
completely different
viewpoint.
So we actually got two or
three other [? x ?]
[? game ?] developers who
are working at Google.
And we sat down for about 120
days and said, let's make a
game in HTML5.
Let's take our viewpoint
and how we do it.
And that's where the GRITS
game came from.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: And
it's actually
funny because I view--
this is a course so
close to my heart.
I think all of education
should be games.
And being educated should be a
gaming experience where you do
something and you get
to the next level.
And before in Angry Birds,
you learn how to operate
slingshots.
And now you can play the game
of how to learn how
to program a game.
Which is really cool.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
That's really incredible.
And Sean, what we'd love to do
now is actually turn it over
to you to show the website and
what it's actually like to
take the course.
SEAN BENNETT: Sure.
We can go ahead and look
at the site right now.
I've got it pulled up here.
So this is the main
Udacity site.
It's got a number of
courses up on here.
And you can see HTML5
game development.
KATHERINE MILLER: And with that,
can you actually just
use that as a chance to talk
about what type of courses you
do offer through Udacity?
SEAN BENNETT: Absolutely.
Yeah.
I think the main differentiator
with our
courses at Udacity
is interaction.
It's not about passive
learning at all.
And so if we go in here to
our classroom, which the
instructor is currently
setting up.
And you can see that
we come to a video.
And it looks like Peter is in
the middle of a canvas unit.
He hasn't finished it yet.
And there's a short video.
But then after that, you
immediately get taken to a
coding section where the
student has to--
SEBASTIAN THRUN: It's kind
of flashing right now.
SEAN BENNETT: Oh,
it's flashing?
OK.
Oh.
Is it good?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: No.
SEAN BENNETT: No?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: It's
a flashing game.
SEAN BENNETT: Flashing game.
It's a flashing game
apparently.
COLT MCANLIS: We're
not using Flash.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: It's HTML5.
I can guarantee you.
SEAN BENNETT: We're having
some technical issues.
So go to the site.
But like I was saying, I think
the main thing is student
interaction.
That's the primary difference, I
think, that our pedagogy has
that other platforms
don't necessarily.
And that's certainly
more traditional.
Lecture halls do not have.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
I guess the wisdom here is the
only way to learn how to be a
game developer is
to write games.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: So anything
else is secondary.
You can have an instructor
that helps
you and assists you.
But if you don't write games,
you're not going to become a
game developer.
And that's what we're
tyring to do.
So if you go there, you
will write games.
COLT MCANLIS: And game
developers, in all of my time,
I've found that they are the
most impatient developers I've
ever worked with.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Because they see
Angry Birds and they see
Temple Run 2.
And they go, I can make that.
And they want their
game in the store
in like three months.
And that's what I love about the
Udacity format, is that it
literally puts them in the
driver's seat and says, learn
it by doing it.
And that's the way game
developers work.
We're very impatient.
We want it done and we
want it done now.
SEAN BENNETT: And I think
project-based education is
just very powerful for, not only
teaching you what to do,
but also giving you kind of a
portfolio at the end of things
that's like, this is something
I've built
that I can point to.
It's not a piece of paper
that is maybe worth
something, maybe not.
It's, I've done this.
And that's a really
powerful feeling.
KATHERINE MILLER: And actually,
that leads in
beautifully to the next
question, which was actually
going to be not just the
pedagogy behind this game, but
really behind Udacity
as a whole.
And the massive online
open courses.
So I think you started to hit at
that, that there's kind of
something consistent in all of
your courses, which is kind of
being program, problem-solving
based around.
That people aren't just
passively learning, but
they're actually going to be
creating something throughout
the course.
Would you say that that's--
SEAN BENNETT: Oh, absolutely.
Do you want to add to that?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
Obviously, all my own learning
has been by trying something
and failing and then getting
up and trying it again.
And I've never gotten much out
of listening to professors.
Myself included.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: But
[INAUDIBLE].
Rather than thinking about like
online MOOCs as taking
the lecture and putting it
online, we think of it as
taking the exercise and
putting those online.
Because those are
much more fun.
And we want this kind of--
we almost want this
gamification
effect on our students.
Like they get into a challenging
situation and it's
really hard and they spend
hours trying to solve it.
But when they solve it, they
solve it themselves.
And they can fall asleep
saying, wow.
I did this.
These are, for me, the most
powerful moments of life, when
I succeed in solving
a problem.
And I think the same should
be true for our students.
SEAN BENNETT: To me, it's
actually pretty similar to
puzzle design and games.
Is that you have to make the
player actually figure it out.
You can't tell them
how to do it.
But there's a right level.
You can't be too easy.
It can't be too hard.
It has to have that
part where, oh.
Yeah.
I get it now.
And that's a hugely
powerful moment.
PETER LUBBERS: I think a lot of
people approach any sort of
online class, also, with what
they know from the past.
So they say, oh, yeah.
It's just a video.
And then when they actually
look at it
they're like, oh, wow.
This is actually completely
different.
This may actually
be even better
than what they expected.
So it's a mind shift for many
people as well to just get
into this for the first time.
KATHERINE MILLER: Absolutely.
And I think that you did touch
upon this a little bit, the
distinction between a MOOC
environment versus it being a
more traditional environment.
But especially for those of you
who have been professors,
have you seen a shift towards
this type of instruction in
classrooms?
Or do you still see that right
now, these online courses are
the place that this innovation
in pedagogy is happening?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Well, to be
fair to traditional colleges,
a lot of professors
try to do this.
Like if you go to humanities,
you get your homework
assignments and you spend the
in-class experience discussing
it rather than lecturing.
In engineering, lecturing
is the dominant mode.
And it's the only way you can
manage maybe 30, 100 students.
It's just the best you
can do in class.
The nice thing about the online
is we can do stuff you
could never do in a classroom.
Online can wait for you.
You can watch the same
video twice.
Or five times.
Or 10 times.
You're given as much time as it
takes to become a master.
There's no December 14 final
exam comes along and if you
aren't prepared, tough luck.
We give you like a
failing grade.
No, no.
You have another month.
And just take your time.
And get to the point where
you know how to do it.
That's something you
just cannot do
in a physical classroom.
And that's what you
get at Udacity.
KATHERINE MILLER: And I think
there also, you mentioned
this, about one of your
passions is the
accessibility piece.
And I was having fun with this
question beforehand, because
some of our guests have fears
of alien ants and zombies.
And my thought is, wow.
This is amazing.
If they're holed up in their
houses avoiding zombies, they
could still access
this course.
But I think there's probably
a deeper nugget there from
accessibility as well.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
You can do game development
even under zombie attacks.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: What else
are you going to do?
COLT MCANLIS: Udacity should
definitely be part of
everyone's emergency
zombie kit.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: You can use
that, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KATHERINE MILLER: But
there is something
deeper to that as well.
SEAN BENNETT: Absolutely.
Yeah.
I think the most powerful
way to point
this out is that almost--
actually larger than 70% of our
student population in this
course right now is
international.
They're not US students.
And they're from all over.
It's not a few countries here
that really stand out.
It's India.
It's Eastern Europe.
It's everywhere.
PETER LUBBERS: The
Netherlands.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
We have a lot of people
in the Netherlands.
We actually have a number of
people in Ghana, I think.
It's really, really impressive,
just how
widespread it is all
over the world.
KATHERINE MILLER: Absolutely.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
And if you look at it, 7 of the
10 most fastest growing
economies are in Africa.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: It's an
amazing place to be, an
amazing continent to be.
And there, I think traditionally
education is
much harder to get by.
And I think what's going to
happen is they're just going
to leapfrog us and
everybody else in
their education medium.
And obviously, with an enormous
distribution of cell
phones and mobile, there's an
opportunity to really go out
and educate those people.
KATHERINE MILLER: Yeah.
That's really incredible.
Switching gears a little bit.
So Colt, you have had the
experience of teaching at SMU
as you mentioned.
And now you're teaching with
Udacity in this is much
larger, more scaled
environment.
What's that experience
been like?
COLT MCANLIS: It's
been fantastic to
be honest with you.
Teaching at SMU was great.
The fact that they have an
entire school dedicated to
game development curriculum
was fantastic.
There was always a little
bit of sort of a focus
issue for me there.
Because you always walk this
line about what data you're
serving that has to deal with
the curriculum for getting the
piece of paper at the
end of things versus
what's super relevant.
And I'm still actually
in contact
with a lot of my students.
During my time there I probably
had about 120 students.
And they'll still send me
messages and ask me questions
and say, I'm having this
problem in my career.
And that's been amazing.
What we're seeing-- and the
reason for that is because
they allowed me to come to the
table and give them these
stories about game development,
and teach in a
way that fit that setup.
And the great part about
Udacity is it's
like that on steroids.
If you actually take our canvas
courses, you'll get
sort of our cool little nuggets
of information about
the games industry.
Dangerous Dave and copyright
infringement.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Loading times
in [? Detroit ?]
Prime.
That's really just, at the
heart of it, so cool.
And the fact that there's
already so many students that
are on the message boards
finding the problems, fixing
issues, answering
each other's--
don't take this the wrong way.
But as an instructor, that
makes my job really easy.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: When you've got
40,000 students answering each
other's questions, you
never feel alone.
That's great.
SEAN BENNETT: And there's
more to that, too.
When you're answering another
student's questions, in my
experience learning how this
course works and the code base
and everything, you learn
more by teaching than
any other way probably.
I'm not a game developer.
And part of the challenge here
for me was learning how this
code actually works, how
this game works.
And why it works the way it
does, I think is probably the
thing that took the longest.
COLT MCANLIS: You and Calvin
had the hardest job.
Because you had to translate
all this gobbledygook in my
head and put it into
normal human speak.
So hats off to these guys.
They worked overtime on
being translators.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
One thing that I think is really
interesting from what
you've said, though--
especially the
interactivity piece--
I actually have a background
in higher education.
And when this massively open
online coursework started
coming out, my first reaction
was, how does that work with
some of the benefits or
potential perceived strengths
of a more traditional
environment?
Kind of the infrastructure of
the student body and academic
affairs and all of those things
that can, hopefully,
drive people to success.
But it sounds like,
in many ways--
I think the word somebody had
mentioned was self-governing.
It seems like these people
have actually created
communities that are keeping
them enrolled in the courses
and moving forward.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We live
in the 21st century.
And it's time for us to go
to the 21st century now.
KATHERINE MILLER: I know.
When I was studying, it was
right on the border of that
21st century.
So we hadn't quite tipped the
balance in my classes yet.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I had this
painful experience.
I'm trying to partially cover
curriculum with the way it's
being taught.
And do some crazy great
things like just go to
HTML5 and just do it.
And in the class curriculum,
there's something called
factoring polynomials.
It's like you take a long
polynomial and you have to
break it into pieces.
And I'm a Stanford professor.
I've done math all my life.
And I've never ever factored a
polynomial in my entire life.
And I know nobody in the planet
who would know-- anyone
who should care about factoring
polynomials.
So I got together a whole bunch
of educators and said,
let's make a video on motivating
to students why
they should care about factoring
polynomials.
And there's no answer.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: It's like, some
mathematicians wrote it
into the books a long time ago
and said this is part of it.
And you'll be foregoing all
these other opportunities.
I think if I had a choice and
go to a 16-year-old and
[? say ?] learn about factoring
polynomials or learn
HTML5, you should learn HTML5.
Because that's so much cooler.
PETER LUBBERS: In fact,
I can attest to that.
I have a 15 and a
17-year-old son.
They'd agree.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I think there's
a lot to be done.
I think everybody should be
able to be a teacher.
Everybody should be able
to be a student and a
teacher at the same time.
Being a teacher is the best
way to be a student.
We should discover what makes
teaching go well.
I just refuse to believe that a
lecture class with like 500
and kids and a professor
lecturing chemistry is the
best that society can do.
It's probably the best you
could do 300 years ago.
But guys, wake up.
We live in the 21st century.
KATHERINE MILLER: Fair enough.
Fair enough.
So with that, an interesting
thing that we are doing with
this is a little bit
of a hybrid model.
There actually is an
in-person component
to this, isn't there?
SEAN BENNETT: That's right.
Yeah.
So we're trying something
new out.
And really excited about it.
It's basically a study group.
So we are launching,
basically, a
unit or two per week.
And what we figured is there's a
lot of people-- for example,
I run the San Francisco
HTML5 user group--
there's a bunch of Udacity
Meetups in the Bay Area.
And we said, why don't we get
together a nice room-- like
100 people can fit
in this room--
and do like office hours
or study group?
And so what was interesting
about that is, we will also be
live streaming that.
So starting next week, on
Wednesday-- and we'll put the
link to that--
we're going to have, basically,
a series of-- well,
it starts on Wednesday.
But it's going to be
every Monday night.
And we're going to be--
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: Well,
Presidents' Day.
PETER LUBBERS: Exactly.
Yeah.
Because of the holiday.
So we're going to be doing this
for about eight weeks on
Monday nights.
And so we'll be there--
Colt, Sean, myself
will be there.
Maybe Sebastian will be there.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I hope so.
PETER LUBBERS: And we'll
actually deal
with people's problems.
So the idea is people would
take the course.
They will do everything
in a unit.
And then bring all their
questions to the live stream,
to the room.
And we'll deal with
all the questions.
And we'll have a Moderator
up like we had for today.
So really trying to couple
that a little bit.
At least for the first
eight weeks.
We're not going to keep doing
that indefinitely.
And of course, after that, it's
completely self-serve,
the same as everything else.
But it'll be an interesting
experiment.
KATHERINE MILLER: And have any
of your other courses had this
hybrid component to them?
SEAN BENNETT: The closest we've
come, I think, is Office
Hours when we originally
started, where we would just
have videos that we
would put up.
Students would ask questions
in the forum.
And then the most popular
questions, we would answer in
a short segment and put
them up on a more
or less weekly basis.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
So Peter and I had
a Google Hangout.
It was also broadcast
over YouTube.
And we had 12,000 students at
the same time online just
listening to their
conversation.
And we picked student
questions.
And we didn't pick all
12,000 obviously.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We used a
Google Moderator to have
people brought [? up ?]
[? all these ?]
questions.
And even 12,000 students don't
have 12,000 questions.
They have maybe 20,
30, 50 questions.
PETER LUBBERS: Well, that's
precisely the huge
benefit of the scale.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: And the
interesting thing was, half
the questions were
technical and the
other half were personal.
Like, what does it mean
to work at Google?
What does it mean to work
in the United States?
As a German-- or
as a European--
how to get there.
And it was really interesting
to see how much people
benefited from that
discussion.
KATHERINE MILLER: I see.
It really does seem like
they're just really
interesting, innovative ways
to be making it scalable,
accessible.
And yet at the same time really
addressing the benefits
of what it is to be
in a classroom.
That while the lecture format
may no longer be as relevant,
there's still the benefits
of interacting with the
professor, interacting with
your fellow students.
And it sounds like you've
come up with some really
interesting ways of doing that
without removing the human
element, if you will.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
We didn't want to just, OK.
It's finished.
Goodbye.
We'll move on to the
next project.
We want to really also
learn from--
clearly there's ways that
we can improve.
And we can get a much closer
look if we keep the finger on
the pulse of what is
actually happening.
COLT MCANLIS: And I was very
excited because there was a
lot of crazy game developer
stories that we had to leave
out of the course that
I now have a medium
to give to the people.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: So if you want
more crazy developer stories,
come to these study groups.
SEAN BENNETT: Don't do it.
Don't do it.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Excellent.
And with that, I'm not sure if
these are statistics that you
can share or address,
but success rates.
So kind of x% of students enroll
and over a certain
percent of time there's
a certain
completion rate with classes.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
The completion rates.
They waver between
20% and, say, 8%.
And they're to be taken
with a grain of salt.
Because it's so easy
to enroll.
You just go to the
site and enroll.
And in fact, in the past, half
of all classes were taken by
people who didn't even enroll.
And we didn't count them
in the statistics.
But staying through
a class is effort.
Learning is not easy.
It's like weight loss.
A lot of people sign up for
the gym and don't go.
And they think they're going
to lose weight that way.
And if you really want
to learn HTML5, you
have to come to class.
And have you participate.
And that's hard.
KATHERINE MILLER: It's
not just osmosis.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: And these are
real, challenging classes.
These are not watching YouTube
animated comic strips.
KATHERINE MILLER: Absolutely.
So, Colt, many of the people who
are on the stream now are
maybe enrolled.
Some may not.
For those who haven't gotten
started yet or maybe partway
or even are considering,
why should
someone take this course?
COLT MCANLIS: Ah.
Great question.
KATHERINE MILLER: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: So this all, in my
opinion, goes back to what
does a degree say about
your skill set?
And for game developers, any
time you've been in an
interview, the person looking
at your resume says, do you
have a degree?
OK.
Check.
Then you go to the interview
process.
And you realize that you get
questions that have nothing to
do with your undergraduate
curriculum or anything.
You actually get yjr
in-the-trenches questions.
And that's what we've tried to
present in this course, is
what does it really take
to write an HTML5 game?
Not write an HTML5 app
or an HTML5 webpage.
Write a game leveraging the
power of HTML5 technologies.
And so the students that are
in this class, if you're
interested in writing games
and you want to make HTML5
your primary method of choice,
this is the right place to be.
Because you're going to get
that in-the-trenches
experience, that in-the-trenches
technology
that you can't find in
tutorials, you can't find in
standard academia.
This is really the primary
place to get it.
And Udacity's done a great
job of actually
exposing this to the users.
So if you want to make
games, start here.
KATHERINE MILLER: Got it.
And Sean, there's a little bit
of an incentive built into
this as well, isn't there?
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
There is.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: For
us or for them?
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: Everyone.
SEAN BENNETT: Everyone.
So, yeah.
We're running a contest that
we'll be announcing and
putting a link up to where
you build your own game.
And we'll be voting on them.
We'll have students vote on it
and we'll also be judging
games that people make by
the end of the course.
And the winners get some fairly
interesting prizes.
Do you want talk about that?
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
Sure.
So I worked on getting at least
one ticket to Google I/O
this year, which as anyone
that's been trying to get a
ticket knows, that's really,
really hard to get.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm not
even sure I'm
allowed to go this year.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: Probably not.
SEAN BENNETT: That's
a good thing.
PETER LUBBERS: It
was your ticket.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: We'll
talk offline.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
PETER LUBBERS: And
then, of course,
the other grand prize--
SEAN BENNETT: And the other part
of the grand prize is a
future cameo appearance
in a Udacity course.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
KATHERINE MILLER: Very cool.
PETER LUBBERS: Full trip
paid and everything.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
We'll get you out here.
We'll put you in a course
for a [? bit. ?]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: And if
I happen to be with a
self-driving car--
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah, who knows?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Take
you for a ride.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: It's
really cool.
SEAN BENNETT: But the thing I
like about this contest is
it's not actually about
completing the course.
That's not the goal.
The goal is actually
building something.
Building your own game or
building a game with a group
of your friends.
And that's, I think, the power
of this course and the power
of what we can do with this.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Those are the questions
that I have.
Before we move over
to the moderated
questions, any final comments?
Have I hit them all?
PETER LUBBERS: I think so.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Well, we've had a very, very
active Q&A board going on.
So I'm really excited to
jump right into those.
So that the first one that
we have is for Colt.
And the question is, is a game
like the one we are building
during the course--
one that uses canvas
and Box2D--
is it portable to a native
mobile app using PhoneGap or
similar technologies?
COLT MCANLIS: Ah.
Absolutely.
This is one of the great things
about writing in HTML5
technology is, at its core,
it's really built to span
devices and a number
of mediums.
Now, when you're using PhoneGap
or sort of web view
components, you have to do
some modifications to the
source code, especially dealing
with the fact that
PhoneGap doesn't have
WebSocket support.
So you actually have to go get
the socket.io plug-in and
install that for PhoneGap.
There's tutorials on how
to do this online.
But the core principles
are there.
The core principles work.
The standard source
code works.
Besides there's some
modifications you have to do
with the native wrappers.
But other than that, that's one
of the great things about
HTML5, is the technology.
It definitely is there.
And it's definitely usable.
KATHERINE MILLER: Great.
And we'll continue
with you for the
questioning for the moment.
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
KATHERINE MILLER: The Udacity
HTML5 game programming course
content, will it have basic or
advanced content such as
Physics, HTML5 database,
WebSocket, additional
JavaScript libraries?
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So what we did when we took the
GRITS framework as a game,
we actually split it into
two components.
There's the server side
and the client side.
And this first class is actually
just all the client
side components.
Hopefully we'll get a chance to
do a server side soon, you
guys on that side
of the table.
So the client side stuff
actually involves a lot of
things like canvas rendering,
physics, of course with Box2D,
as well as other principles
that are needed for game
development specifically.
So talking about object oriented
patterns, entity
patterns, how to load maps, how
to use editors properly,
how to actually get your
sounds playing.
Really, this first class is
everything you need to do to
get pixels on the screen, sound
in your ears, and things
bumping into each other
in awkward manners.
Hopefully the next course, we
can actually talk about things
like WebSocket, Node.js,
how to host things.
How to actually get player
versus player environment,
real time networking, collision
detection that's all networked.
There's many good things
to come out of it.
KATHERINE MILLER: OK.
Excellent.
Thank you.
Peter, this is a broader
question.
Could you please post a roadmap
of web development the
way you see it?
There are endless--
SEAN BENNETT: Wow.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: Glad
you got that.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KATHERINE MILLER: Maybe
this is good
feedback for marketing.
[? Think I'm ?] asking
you and then you.
There are endless resources
for education
all over the internet.
One might get lost quickly
without a guide.
PETER LUBBERS: Wow.
That's a great question.
Yeah, so--
well, we're doing our part.
I think, as Sebastian mentioned,
we're really
excited to build more.
And the exact details of when
the next course and all that,
we don't have that yet.
But we're very excited.
And clearly, it's not going to
be just this course or a
series of courses on Udacity.
We're actually working on a lot
of different initiatives
around this.
Things like WebPlatform.org to
sort of have the one canonical
reference for all of the
documentation of the web.
Great courses like this.
There's other web development
courses.
Yeah.
If you follow us along,
we'll try to come
up with this roadmap.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: It's
a big question.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: That's
a big undertaking.
KATHERINE MILLER: Yeah.
It is.
Any additional thoughts?
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I
completely agree.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: Nice.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
And Sean, this is a
question for you.
What do you think about using
TDD or unit testing--
actually, maybe it's a
question for Colt.
Either can jump in.
Using TDD or unit testing
for game developing?
I have seen you use Jasmine
at the tests.
Do you have plans to introduce
this technology at the course?
SEAN BENNETT: OK.
We are using--
well, we were using Jasmine.
We're switching over because
there have been a number of
technical issues with some of
the grading, which we're
working on fixing.
Thanks for sticking with us.
[LAUGHTER]
SEAN BENNETT: But I would
love to do that.
I think doing TDD or BDD is a
course, at least, in itself.
So I don't think interleaving
it with this is really the
right way to do it.
Colt, I leave it to you for
its bigger role in game
development.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
So let's put it this way.
Is that debugging is sad.
Testing is awesome.
So it's really bad to actually
have to drill through a
million lines of code
to figure out
why something's broken.
It's really nice when a unit
test tells you it is.
That being said, it
is not done in
game development enough.
Because a lot of the
game development
process is very iterative.
You have to imagine that you've
got designers and
artists and programmers and
producers and business people
all pouncing on top of you to
create this amazing piece of
content that's going to
touch millions of
people across the world.
And because of that, you
have to iterate.
You got to be really quick.
You got to put in code,
put in content.
Rip it out because
it's not fun.
Evaluate that feedback loop.
And with that, there's not a
lot of testing done in unit
systems and automation.
And that's wrong, I think.
I think we should add
a lot more of that.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
What you just described is true
for Google as a company.
COLT MCANLIS: Exactly.
Right.
SEAN BENNETT: It actually sounds
like building a course.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Exactly.
And that's why I think a lot
of it should be adopted.
A lot of game developers take
the incorrect view that, hey,
I'm going to write this code and
put it up there and make
$1 million.
And that code base is done.
Well, that's incorrect.
I've worked for companies that
were using code bases that
were almost 12 years old and
still did not have unit tests
anywhere in that code.
So as a game developer,
learning this
is a very good strategy.
Not necessarily as a game
developer, just as a good
software engineer.
So I think there should be
more of it in game dev.
If you're out there and you're
listening, definitely take
advantage of it.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Good message.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: And you seem
really, really enthusiastic so
I'm gonna throw you
another one.
COLT MCANLIS: Sweet.
It's the caffeine, really.
KATHERINE MILLER: Will you
also use some HTML5 game
developer framework
like Crafty.js or
LimeJS during the course?
I know that these are the
basics with Vanilla JS.
Maybe some framework
usage could be
applied in SQL courses.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
So our goal for this course
is to give you as much
to-the-metal processing
as possible.
We don't want to teach
you how to use
someone else's framework.
We want to teach you how to
write things from scratch.
Because that's the difference
between teaching a man to fish
and teaching a man
how to be a fish.
I think that works.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Does that work?
I don't know.
SEAN BENNETT: Maybe.
COLT MCANLIS: So the only actual
other library we use is
Box2D.js, which is an entire
physics and collision library.
And the reason we do that is
because we really didn't have
enough time to teach
you everything
about physics and collision.
Besides that, we try
to keep any other
frameworks out of it.
In the future, like I said, if
we do get a chance to do some
service side courses we're
gonna be talking about
Node.js, Socket.IO.
Basically these tack on
components that are really
easy to drop in and provide
functionality that aren't part
of your core game development.
So maybe we'll see
a little bit more
of that in the future.
KATHERINE MILLER: Now a question
for you, Peter.
HTML5 seems to have no solution
for protecting code.
Are there any upcoming
technologies that look to
protect my code from
unauthorized use?
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
That's definitely one of the
classic things that people
will raise.
That's like, all right, that's
a problem for my game.
Of course, you have the standard
ways to obfuscate
your code and things like that
and compress and so on.
But that remains a little bit
of a point for people.
Not sure if there's a lot of
immediate things coming out in
the near future.
SEAN BENNETT: [INAUDIBLE].
PETER LUBBERS: I don't think
that's changing.
In a way, the beauty of a lot
of the web is that you can
view the source of it.
That also has the downside
of viewing source on it.
COLT MCANLIS: I've talked to a
lot of game developers about
this problem.
They're very hesitant about
protecting their assets when
they move to HTML5.
And there's a couple different
ways you can take it.
First off is, you can view all
the source code for Gmail.
Yet reverse engineering
Gmail is actually a
pretty daunting task.
And the code that actually ships
to the client, as far as
game development is concerned,
is really just
the tip of the iceberg.
Like if you've ever done game
development, you realize the
massive part of code and content
you generate is all on
the back end with tooling and
setting up user databases and
understanding content
creation pipelines.
Compression, texture
generation.
The tools involved are
monumental in scope.
What the user actually
gets on the client
side is really small.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: So we
need another course.
A back end course.
PETER LUBBERS: That's right.
COLT MCANLIS: I like
your style.
SEAN BENNETT: Or maybe
a few courses.
PETER LUBBERS: But I mean,
really, what you get is
there's so much rich
interactivity now on the
client, the code that's doing
that is really not sort of the
business logic.
That doesn't have to
be shipped down
to the client either.
So, yeah.
It's like Colt said.
You have what you need.
You're probably not going to
find a lot of secrets in there
that people don't want
to give away.
KATHERINE MILLER: I see.
And I think we're going to
continue speaking with you.
Lots of game-oriented
questions.
But others, please jump in
as you have responses.
With the recent improvements
to WebRTC, do you think it
would be possible to
create multi-person
MMO voice chat systems?
Thoughts?
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
SEAN BENNETT: Yes.
PETER LUBBERS: Yes.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETER LUBBERS: In fact, I'm
thinking it might be good for
the Udacity platform.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: The main thing
holding back web based
games in my mind is a lack
of controller support.
Do you know of ways either being
considered or already
being worked on to
solve game input?
COLT MCANLIS: Absolutely.
SEAN BENNETT: Gamepad.
COLT MCANLIS: Gamepad support
was actually added to Chrome
as of Chrome 18, I believe.
This will actually support your
Xbox 360, as well as PS3
style controllers.
And I do believe this was part
of the spec and actually is
inside of WebKit too.
So that means you'll have
that access inside
of Firefox as well.
I don't know if there's any
other controller support APIs
that are available there yet.
I know there's some
neurocontrols that are sort of
making their way around.
And also connect controls
and things like that.
But I know that the spec as it
is, you do get access to
handheld controllers.
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
So this, I think, probably
would love
comments from both sides.
Can you offer a certificate or
college credit or employer
credit from Google for student
[? achievements? ?]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Well, so
Udacity has gotten involved
heavily in college credit.
Not at the HTML5 class because
it's not a class that's being
taught right now.
But I would encourage everybody
who completes this
class and is in colleges, go
to your college and say, I
want this for credit.
And see what happens.
Because the skill you'll learn
is probably better and
stronger than most computer
science classes
I've seen in my life.
And that's the way it
should be going.
Employer credit.
Udacity has helped students
find jobs, if you
look student profiles.
We have profile pages
and so on.
We have about 300 or so--
350, I think-- companies right
now look at those CVs.
And they've been actually asking
for the kinds of skills
that this course gives
to students.
A lot of companies go to the
web right now and need
interactive skills for
their products and so
on for their websites.
And they're becoming more
and more game-like.
So it's a great skill to have.
Is there guaranteed employment?
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: No.
But I think it's definitely
shifting.
In the past, it was really
resume based.
And now it's much more
like, OK, so you're
a JavaScript coder.
Well, where's your GitHub
repository?
Like how are you-- if you're
not known in the community,
then that's already
a red flag.
And you can have all the resume
you want for that.
So it's definitely shifting.
Again, there's no guarantees.
Take the class, get a job.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
I think the employer credit is
much more portfolio based,
essentially.
I think if you have that,
then you're going to
get employer credit.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: The other
thing we've found is in
talking to employers, that the
skills that are non-obvious
that really make a difference.
Usually the soft communication
skills.
So in every class we find these
like 10 or 20 or 30
students who are just immensely
good in helping
other students.
And that's something that
employers care about.
Because no problem in real life
is ever solved with a
single individual.
They're always solved with teams
of people that involve
multi-disciplinary business
people and legal
people and so on.
So those are even [INAUDIBLE].
So if you're engaged in the
class, I recommend to you,
help others.
That's actually a good thing for
yourself, for others, and
for employability.
SEAN BENNETT: We've actually
hired a few of them.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: So
there you go.
SEAN BENNETT: It works.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: They're
awesome people.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
They're amazing.
KATHERINE MILLER: It's
kind of the contest.
Really, we addressed in some
of this as well in terms of
the incentive to create
something that could go into a
portfolio, as well as the
opportunity to guest star.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Or you
start your own company
and make the next--
KATHERINE MILLER: Exactly.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: --Angry Birds,
and buy the company
that didn't want to hire you.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
A Udacity question here.
Does Udacity also have plans to
host collaborative projects
and maybe include top
students in the
classes into those projects?
Think this can be a significant
experience for
students and may attract
more employers.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We
would love to.
And I'll leave it at that.
SEAN BENNETT: We have a
secondary website that's
Udacity projects.
I forget what the
exact URL is.
But where we've created for the
web development course,
the basic one, where students
would host their blog or their
project that they made after the
had completed that course.
And a lot of them had really
cool ideas that were just
little things that were
useful to them.
It wasn't necessarily something
that they wanted to
build for someone else.
They're like, now I know
how to build this.
So I want to.
And I'm going to.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yeah.
That site-- it wasn't
collaborative.
But one student from Germany
built a search engine for
video games-- sorry, videos.
And I showed it to the executive
team at YouTube and
said, look.
This is how your search or
[? access ?] of YouTube videos
should look like and this is
what we're doing right now.
And without going into too much
detail, that specific
piece of work was just
blow away amazing.
It had a way to index many
videos at the same time.
You could type in a keyword
like George W. Bush.
And then it would find the
mentioning of all these names
and all these videos.
And then make a new
video that just
superimposed all these mentions.
And it was a really
cool experience.
KATHERINE MILLER: Very cool.
Shifting back to HTML5
and games.
Little of an opinion question.
The good and bad parts
of HTML5 games.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm gonna let
you take that one first.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: Well, of course
the good part, also a couple
of other questions raised
is like the portability.
Just having a link to a place
and being able to
instantly play that.
That's really the good part.
The incredible reach
you would have.
Bad part.
Right now, there are certain
things, let's say we're
talking towards everything
is moving to mobile.
There are certain lower level
APIs like the device access
APIs and things that are not
completely there yet.
But it's moving very fast.
Here at Google, we're working
really, really hard to make
that happen.
Getting closer and
closer to that.
Sometimes you see a
specification for an
[INAUDIBLE] that then
needs to, of
course, be an older browser.
So it takes a little longer.
But that might be a
bad part I guess.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: The velocity
has been fast.
It's quite amazing.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I used to think
that you had to have
lower level machine access to
do something interesting.
And that's really
changing now.
COLT MCANLIS: And it's
getting a lot closer.
And that's one of the pros and
cons I have for web game
development.
Is that you can and do a lot of
amazing things with HTML5.
But you kind of hit the top of
the limit when you try to
reach a certain experience.
When you try to do more than
about 300 to 500 draws on a
canvas per frame, you actually
kind of max out, even on
desktop machines.
So getting above that, getting
more of that performance, is
going to be your cap.
And game developers are
constantly demanding more.
So if you're kind of doing a
2D environment type game,
HTML5 works really well.
If you're really trying to do
something 3D and immersive,
you got to kinda go
over to WebGL.
And that's got a whole
different suite of
[? performance ?]
environments.
One of the other bad sides is
that because the web is
fantastic--
or Chrome specifically
is great at
actually being very secure--
we reduce your ability
to get access to
lower level file systems.
Which means that we kind of get
rid of the ability that
games need to actually
cache local content.
So if you actually looked at
the latest statistics, most
mobile games nowaday are
anywhere between one and four
gigs worth of content.
As you see this curve start
moving towards the web, you're
going to try to start
transferring four gigs through
a Wi-Fi connection to someone
in a coffee shop?
This actually doesn't
work very well.
And so I'm very concerned
moving forward about the
ability to decompress content,
store content, game developers
getting that content, first
pixel to screen.
Getting rid of load bars has
been something that I've spent
a lot of my career
trying to do.
And now we're seeing all of
these same problems come back
in HTML5 web development.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Do you think
there's gonna be solution for
this for HTML5?
That your phone just caches
vast amounts of data?
COLT MCANLIS: So there are
some solutions in flight.
Things like AppCache and index
storage and file system.
And I think those
are good starts.
I think I AppCache actually has
a lot of problems because
it tries to obfuscate too
much from the developer.
Game developers, we're used to
having control of the native
file system.
And because of that, we've got
30 years of technology that
show us how to properly segment,
cache, flow, things
along those lines.
Until we get that level of
control in HTML5, I think
we're going to have problems.
So I hope we get
there one day.
I really hope that web
developers realize that,
again, games push the limits.
And if we want to make web apps
great, we should support
game development, because
that's really
where you want to be.
So I think--
if you believe this too, email
your congressman or
international political
representative
or something else.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: About HTML5?
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
KATHERINE MILLER: You could put
a platform up about the
Death Star.
So--
COLT MCANLIS: There you go.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah, exactly.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: We have
remedial classes in math on
the web as well for
congressmen.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: Just the
guests today have been
incredibly generous
with their time.
Wanted to do a quick
time check.
We're coming up on
about 11:30.
We have some additional
questions to ask.
If people have a little bit more
time, maybe take a couple
more questions?
PETER LUBBERS: Sure.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
PETER LUBBERS: Just want to
mention, we will go through--
we're not going to get
to all the questions.
There's been a just
incredible amount.
We will go through afterwards
and answer all of them.
Don't worry.
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: Great.
So why don't we take two or
three more questions?
That work?
PETER LUBBERS: Sure.
Sure.
KATHERINE MILLER: Great.
I think you guys have hinted
at thoughts around this
already, but what is the chance
of a part two course or
other platform dependent
content?
SEAN BENNETT: So I
think everyone
would love to do that.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Yep.
SEAN BENNETT: I think everyone
is ready to go ahead.
The question is what
more do we do?
Really, from my end,
I would love to--
like you were talking
about PhoneGap
and porting to mobile.
I would love to do some content
on how do you actually
port to a mobile?
Because that's a huge market.
I don't know.
What would you guys--
PETER LUBBERS: We're actively
thinking about it.
We don't have any
firm plans yet.
But really, mobile
performance.
The server side--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COLT MCANLIS: Really, step one
is everyone take a nap.
Because a lot goes
into this course.
Calvin, go to the gym.
Do some rock climbing.
Get some sleep.
SEAN BENNETT: He climbs a lot.
COLT MCANLIS: He does
climb a lot.
Huge hands.
One of the interesting things is
that if you guys loved this
course and you want to see more
of it, then definitely
make your voice known.
Get your friends to
take the course.
Let's make this a smashing
success so it's a slam dunk
that more people are interested
in it and that we
should definitely do
a second course.
So email your friends,
email your family.
Get your grandma to
take the course.
She needs to know how
to program HTML5.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: I have to admit
I'm actually impressed
that you guys can talk about
the second course at this
point in time after
all the pain--
[LAUGHTER]
PETER LUBBERS: It's like
having a baby.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Having a baby,
there's a certain period
where you just don't want
to talk about it.
And you're talking about a
second course already.
I think all of Google is kind
of looking at the experience
of this one class, see how
it comes together.
How good it is.
What's the [? impression ?]
from the community.
So, again, I should also
emphasize for you on the
online, there's a lot of
flaws in the course.
We have grading difficulties
and so on.
We're redoing some videos.
I got stuck in the course,
I should openly admit.
But I'm not a very
good [INAUDIBLE].
So send us suggestions.
And be somewhat patient with us
as explore this new medium.
It is going to be so much better
the next time around.
And that's what we're
really shooting for.
SEAN BENNETT: Yeah.
I think that's one of the most
powerful things about these
online courses, that we can
constantly iterate.
If there are problems--
and people have been amazing
about pointing
them out in the forums.
They're sending the
emails about it.
They really have.
And they've been mainly positive
and like, hey.
We know you've got a lot on your
plate and you've got all
these things that you're
trying to do.
I'd really like it if you added
this or changed this or
I wasn't sure what you meant
when you said this.
And that's been amazing.
And I think, going forward,
iterating and improving this
course is going to be
really powerful.
KATHERINE MILLER:
That's great.
One more quick question
before we wrap it up.
And I think that this is quite
a pragmatic question.
I would like to know, in this
course or another, different
ways on how to monetize
a game.
Which is actually something very
top of mind for work that
I'm doing within marketing,
which is not just bringing
technology and training.
But what do you do with
it once you build
that amazing portfolio?
So any thoughts on that?
SEAN BENNETT: That's an
additional course.
[LAUGHTER]
COLT MCANLIS: So
I'll say this.
One of the reasons I've always
loved game development is you
have to be great at everything
to be successful.
You have to bring great content
with great technical
chops with great marketing and
great reach and exposure.
And all of these things have
to come together in this
minute little, little
potential orb.
And if this potential orb
doesn't get out to the masses,
it just all fails apart.
Marketing and monetization
are at the core
of every game developer.
Especially since 2009 when we
saw the indie developer
explosion when smartphones came
on and when we saw the
boom of social gaming come on.
Everyone wants to leave their
big company right now, start
their own company, and
do monetization.
At its core, it's a very
difficult process.
That being said,
there's tons--
probably more now than ever--
of research in this area,
documents in this area, people
specializing in this area.
Understanding the tricks, the
nuances, should you use this
word or that word?
There is better statistics out
right now on the web about how
to monetize your game and the
things you need to do than
there are how to program
your game.
So take that into account.
And that's actually a
great suggestion.
I think that's something worth
looking at moving forward.
KATHERINE MILLER: OK.
Excellent.
And final question.
Zombie apocalypse
or space ants?
COLT MCANLIS: Listen.
So I, for one, welcome our
new insect overlords.
May the crush the zombie hoard
under there tentacley grasps.
SEAN BENNETT: The zombie hoard
will just [? overrun them. ?]
KATHERINE MILLER: Pete?
PETER LUBBERS: I have to
go with the zombies.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Zombies.
SEAN BENNETT: Zombie
space ants.
COLT MCANLIS: You know what?
Always bringing people
together.
SEAN BENNETT: I know.
SEBASTIAN THRUN: Diplomat.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
KATHERINE MILLER: Excellent.
Well, I would just like
to give a huge
thanks to our guests.
Sean Bennett.
Sebastian Thrun.
Peter Lubbers.
And Colt McAnlis.
And again, I'm Katherine Miller
from the Developer
Marketing Team.
This has been a really engaging
conversation.
I hope the audience enjoyed
it as much as we all did.
That's all the programming
we have for today.
And definitely encourage you to
continue tuning into Google
Developers Live for Office
Hours, incredible programming
on Google technologies, as well
as original inspirational
programming.
Thank you for your time.
[MUSIC]